- I just don't
understand salespeople.
It's actually a really
interesting trait that allows
somebody to be a
good salesperson.
It comes down to empathy.
Are you able to put yourself
in the other person's shoes?
I know what I want.
I know how I want it to be but
the reason VaynerMedia's been
successful is because I haven't
been stubborn about forcing all
of my clients who are $9 billion
companies to do it my way.
I'm a little, I'm a speedboat.
You know, me as a brand,
as a person,
as a human, I'm teeny tiny.
VaynerMedia's small.
$100 million, small.
$100 million's small.
My Pepsi client, you know,
they break that much
product in a month.
Small.
Not really, but small.
And so, you need
to be empathetic.
I know how you want it to be.
I know when you're hitting me
up for 15 minutes of my time
what you want out of it.
What do I want out of it?
What do I get out of it?
And that's what I do 24/7/365.
I check my wants at the door
when I go in sales mode and
that's the flip reverse
of how most of the roll.
And that's why I win.
The combination of
running the marathon,
I don't need it right now.
I'm patient as fuck and
I really give a shit
about what you want,
it's why you like me.
It's why this content works.
It's why all these things work.
Because I think about you,
I don't think about myself and
so we need to deploy empathy.
You think you're a good
salesman, show me by deploying
massive empathy and
awareness to the other person.
They're not stupid.
They don't not get it.
They don't get it the way you
want it 'cause
usually it's for you.
Amount of you trying to sell
me right now in the comments on
Insta, I know what you want.
But if you're trying to sell
it to somebody you need to
understand what they want.
That just came out
of straight livin'.
Knowing what I just did the last
12 hours and then going in these
comments sections
and people just,
just not deploying empathy.
If you want something,
you need to reverse
engineer the other person.
(light music)